Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier and welcome to The Mind's Eclipse.
Now this is an interesting game because it supposedly combines
visual novel storytelling with the point click style adventure game
And it's supposed to be a little spooky
And I don't know what to anticipate just judging from the visuals in front of me...
But it should be an interesting experience.
"Let me liberate you."
It all depends on what you're liberating me from, I don't know if I -
oh
Is it a happy marriage you're liberating me from?
I imagine this is gonna be sad
I- I'm gearing myself up for a bit of sad
"The machine..."
"it will save her..."
Save who?
"John, she's awake now..."
(He doesn't know anything about it, for he is John Snow)
"But there isn't much time..."
(But without thyme we can't make the poultry seasoning!)
"I will save her..."
"Hannah..."
oh
Whoooa
Why?
EEERHH
OOOOOOKAY
Eehh
What, is it dissolving her?
Ohww
"Hannah?"
Okay,
"HANNAH!!"
I'm guessing your cure didn't work
If that even was you doing that
"John"
oh
"Who... who's there?"
"You're awake! And here I thought you were a goner"
"I can't see?! My eyes..."
"Yeah give me a sec"
* A Wild AI Appears*
"Hi! Is that better?"
I don't know!
Who are you?
"An AI?"
"Ah, the famed intelligence. I understand it now."
"Wait, why can't I see?"
"Your implants need tweaking"
"There. Much better?"
"Your hands find the scarred eye sockets"
"What happened to my eyes?"
"How about now?"
"Almost"
"Perfect!"
"For my next trick, I will make a lame man walk"
Rude :(
"Let's try that again"
"I'm L. AI designator ECH 35536"
*Jontron ECHS in the distance*
"Nice to meet you, how's it going, can you believe this weather we're having, blah blah"
blapity blah
"Come on, let's go"
"Go where? Where am I? Where's Hannah?"
"You must tell me what's going on"
"You don't have a lot of options here, guy"
"This hospital's running out of oxygen"
Well that just raises further questions!
Are we in space?
*the distant sounds of the Space Core screaming*
"You can stay here but you'll be dead in about 45 minutes"
"Well, 42.76 minutes to be exact"
"But I think you get the picture"
"Alright I'm getting up"
Okay...
"Use the move button to access the map this will allow you to move between rooms"
"Use the inventory button to access the inventory system"
"Use the menu button to" –– I GET IT
"Every environment is interactive. Hover over objects to discover if they are interactive"
Okay, is DIS INURHAKTIV???
Okay.
Hallo! .3.
"Searching the robot reveals a spare Power Cell(™). You pocket it."
"Just an old power cell. I wonder if it even works." (why can't we just read these on the screen)
Okay, why did I pocket it then
I don't know, Mark. Probably for plot related stuff.
*TL;DR don't remove that bowser-y shit or whatever*
Wow, I could not read that. I have no idea why.
Okay,
That seems to be about everything in this room
So I'll move...
Here...
"We need to keep moving!"
"There should be an elevator down the hall, to the right"
"We can get there and we can get to the next level out of here"
"Where is this place? It looks abandoned..."
"It's the CORE Regional Hospital"
Okayyyy
Hello, a forgotten data pad
poor data pad :*(
"The old man is here. And hes not alone.
"Remember the plan. Leave him to me"
"Recently, we've been seeing a spike in foreign nanites in the CORE's air system"
"I'm concerned about their origin."
"Generally, we encounter spikes when a large pilgrimage ship enters the port."
"But we haven't received one of those in weeks."
"We should chat about this in person"
I dunno what that means! *A confused markimoo appears*
Trash is everywhere. *Lazy ass janitors*
A window, to dark to see insiiiide...
Just a whole lotta darkness, everywhere I go!
hello darkness my old friend
I do like the art style
It's very interesting - woah.
What happened here?
A fight?
*TL;DR powers out and some keem fan wanted to suffocate the competition*
But where are we?!
*ugh. more reading*
Okay.
You unscrew your... 'neural bulb'? (yo what the fuck)
*god damnit just read the screen*
*canadian ok*
*im not warning you any more just read the screen when this shit happens god damnit don't you ever listen to me sandra*
Yoh
So the only thing I could pull out of his memory was his mail?
Well, rip his FRIGGIN HANDS OFF!
I don't need to do this again...
*thank the nine*
"A medical droid..." But someone smashed it up in the barricade process.
Doesn't seem to be anything else here.
Did I go the wrong way?
*mumble* to the right...
*still mumbling* down here...
Move!
Bam
"... in an elevator." Is it blood?
Calculatin' a sentry here
*mumble* alright
Doors are sealed, need a knife...
Doors are sealed SHUT...
Grafitti on the wall...
ECHlipse
Something about this ECHlipse
must be sort of, like, some sci-fi...
Unitology bullshit, goin' on.
There's some sort of 'fanatiscism' going on, and some miracles, but...
I imagine they're more *marks fingers* 'science' miracles than anything if this is the level of technology that I've seen around here.
I don't HAVE a knife, though.
No, I don't have a knife yet.
hang on
exit
I gotta go back here
Gotta move down heaeiur
*mark speaks in Simlish*
Hi?!
John!
*distant ECHing*
Well, you stopped calling me 'guy'!
Why are you so interested in saving me and what the hell is THAT?
"I wouldn't go near that!" *no shit you rampancy-lookin' ass cortana ripoff*
Oh
Is THAT all?
Well thank you!
*mark trying to be hip with the kiddos* Thank you for the virtual 'vish'.
OWH NOH
Gaming is gonna destroy society! *WAIT WHAT*
We gawta stahp!
Actually, that's a very interesting thing.
Once virtual reality becomes, like, ACTUAL reality, how can anyone tell the difference?
There will definitely be some addiction if you can enter a world where you can do just about anything.
*thank god i can finally get 8 inches*
Very fascinating, in a few years.
I mean I always like the subject of the technological, like, futuristic games.
A-and stuff like this, because they... they paint an image of the future.
Usually it's a *me mario* very pessimistic image
but
It's in image of the future nonetheless, and it's really interesting to see.
Oh, she's not here!
Well I thought she was here.
Oooh! She's an AI, so I guess she'd be like a digital...
...projection...
Dot dot dot! *im dead*
Very ominiminous.
okay
Yeah, that - that'd be interesting, like
*lip smack*
What's to stop someone? If there is the technology that can let you go in to every virtual world EVER.
Anything your imagination could POSSIBLY come up with
*oh hello overwatch babes*
Like, would people wanna leave? Would people even WANT the real world?
I mean, most people would want the real world.
*quietly and sneakily burps while saying "but"*
There's still gonna be the sub-set of population that would be very interesting in something like that.
Like what do you guys think of that?
What would YOU do?
Would you waste away in a VR pod?
i dunno
Ah, good, surgical cutter!
Good!
*fabulously* Power source is good!
Well it's a guwd thing, I kowld conekt da ba-ery I gawt 2 wifshjkjh de surjicle thing
I'm Campbell, right? Johnathan Campbell? That's MY name! (there are none like it because it is mine)
That's my name! Who's Pravia?
okaaay
my time to shine
always remember that the safewords are niagra, orange, swoose, yellow, tickle.
also, never ever ever change that last sentence pwease. its important. <3
but feel free to change everything else because why the fuck would i give a shit
go watch bo burnham on netflix
[Mark breaks up in the bottom left video, and it turns in to SMPTE color bars]
AHWHATTHEFUCK
dododododDOOOT